هذا الجانب الذي كان يفقده في يفقد في هذه
المنطقه لان الامراء في هذه المنطقه عندما
بدا ايضا محمد بن سعود بفكره التنفيذ
وايضا تطلع للسلطه وايضا بث القوه وايضا
النفود لبلدان المجاوره الرياض سرمدا
الخرج شعرها هؤلاء بان هذا النفود سيؤثر
عليهم ولذلك واجهوه بالقوه ولهذا نجد في
الكتابات الحمدان الشويعر تحدث عن فساد
بعض القضاه اي نعم القضاه ياخذون الرشاوه
ماذا يحضر وجزء منهم ايضا لكن كانوا يعني
وشيوخ يعني ايضا بقصائد رميزان ايضا يشير
الى حاله الامنيه التي كانت سائده في هذه
المنطقه وايضا معاناه الناس في هذه الحاله
ونقول ان المجتمع دائما حتى في قيام
انطلاقه الدوله السعوديه ومشروعها
التوحيدي وايضا نشر الامن لا يمكن ان اكون
رغم النصوص الموجوده الان لا يمكن ان نقول
والله محمد بن سعود انتقل الى هذا البلد
لكي يفعل مثلا يزيل القبر الفلاني او كذا
الصنم الفلاني الانتقال محاوله لملمه هذه
الاطراف وايضا ادخالها بالقوه تحت نفوذ
بواحد ولهذا شعر ايضا هؤلاء الامراء بهذا
الشعور انه سيفقد ايضا نصيبه من الحكم لكن
محمد بن سعود عنده لديه تطلع كبير للسيطره
على هذه دوله
نرمي الكلام جزافا يعني قبل لقائه بالشيخ
محمد
الدرعيه قاومت النفوذ بحكم الاحزان وهي
الاماره الاحساء الاماره الخالديه عماره
الاحساء كانت اقوى اماره في وسط وشرق
الجزيره العربيه ومع ذلك استطاعت الدرعيه
ان يعني تتمتع بنوع من الحكم الذاتي وان
تخرج عكس بقيه البلدات وايضا نجد لها
صراعات ايضا في هذه المنطقه في القوه
المحليه ايضا بقياده ايضا محمد بن سعود
وايضا يعني الدرعيه كانت فتره من الفترات
ايضا هناك عدد الحقيقه من العلماء وايضا
هناك من الدعاء موجودين في الدرعيه يعني
اذا بدانا من مثلا من الشيخ احمد بن عطوه
الى ان نصل الى علماء اسره البا هلي علماء
اسره الباهلي سليمان البالي وكانوا ايضا
بارزين ايضا في هذه المنطقه في ايام
الامام محمد بن مسعود وقبل